hey there everybody welcome to our
December 20th 2018 career QA my name is
Martin McGovern I'm a career coach here
at Udacity I'm excited to chat with you
all about your big career questions this
week and what's on your mind and dig
into our our first topic of the day
which is going to be about job searching
during the holidays it looks like we've
already got some great folks coming in
from all over the world so thank you for
shouting out your location in the chat
if you're still joining feel free to
give a shout at where you're coming in
from maybe even what time it is by you
because we got some definitely
interesting time zones going on I'm
gonna give it a couple of minutes to let
people join and then we will jump into
our initial questions while we're
waiting feel free to add more questions
to the chat and one thing to keep in
mind as we get into it today my
background is in marketing and career
development and though I work with a lot
of technical folks I'm not actually a
developer myself so some of the more
technical questions will have to direct
you to slack to talk to you know
technical folks but will be able to do
today is really figure out you know what
is the best approach to get seen get
heard get in front of people network all
those great things that will help you in
your job search no matter what the
background is again I'm gonna give it a
couple of minutes until to allow people
to join the chat and then we will be
getting into it we got Egypt San Diego
Mexico New Zealand awesome
welcome everybody Georgia
[Music]
all right as soon as the sirens calm
down in the background I'll jump into
our first topic for the day we got
Brazil everyone's saying hello all right
and we are about to get started we got a
good turnout here today so for everyone
who just joined in the last couple
minutes start adding your questions into
the chat will be MUC will be pulling out
the best questions or just as many
questions as you can get to in the hour
today and I will do my best to go as
deep as I can into each one of these so
thank you all for joining us today and
for sharing your thoughts and sharing
your questions we'll be jumping right in
the first thing that we're going to talk
about today is job searching during the
holidays now it's a big topic and we
released a video on it quite recently on
the Udacity career tips video series you
can find that both on LinkedIn and on
YouTube there's a playlist on the
Udacity YouTube channel so feel free to
go check that out but the key thing to
think about is that every year around
this time I'm coaching lots of different
students right and what I notice is as
soon as we get around Thanksgiving time
for anyone who's out here in America
there seems to be this sort of checking
out sort of well no one's paying
attention so I'll come back to this in
the new year but the thing is is that
between Thanksgiving and New Year's is a
lot of time and a lot of like networking
real estate that you're missing out on
because you're deciding to take that
break and what's kind of rough about it
is because we have this sort of
perception in our head that no one's
hiring and no one wants to network we'll
get back to it in the new year what
happens is
everyone comes back on January 1st and
all of a sudden everyone's inboxes and
application listings are just bombarded
with all the new year's resolutions to
get new jobs and everything like that so
competition spikes in early January
whereas right now competition is fairly
low because like I said there's this
general mindset that no one's hiring so
why bother so that means all of you on
the call right now who are still active
who are still trying to figure out what
to do with your career and how to grow
your career in this little holiday
window you're at an advantage to reach
out to people try and set up coffees try
and network go to some holiday parties
that might be posted on meetup.com or
event brain and really get out there and
apply to these jobs that have low
competition right now so I appreciate
you all for jumping on the call today
and I really want to encourage you by
the end of this to continue the job
search through the holidays sure it
might be tough to set up a coffee
meeting around Christmas and other
things but there's a lot of people who
are still in the office who did an ad
vacation time who are kind of in this
like wasteland of an office with no one
to talk to they would love to go out and
grab a peppermint latte or something and
chat about their company in their career
and how they might be able to help you
and all that good stuff so don't feel
like oh we're in the holiday season I
can get nothing done you know take this
time and really we get a little bit
creative or just continue doing what
you're doing so that you can keep
increasing your chances of finding that
next job which is what we're all here to
figure out and today I'm going to be
diving into your questions around either
the holidays if you have a lot of
questions around that topic how to maybe
reach out to people what to say
you know how many jobs should you be
applying to multiple a day most likely
but even more important than that
after you apply who are you connecting
with at the company that's a bigger
question so feel free to jump in the
chat right now we're nearing about a
hundred viewers feel free to
in the chat and add in your questions
and we'll be compiling them and digging
in over the next hour all right question
number one from Hege
and welcome back it's by the way it is
so cool to see so many familiar faces
week over week as we put together these
different types of content all this
different types of content for you in
order to help you in your job search so
I want to give a big shout out to all of
you who have been coming back and re
engaging and sharing this information
with other people you know who are also
in the middle of a job search and in
need of either a tip or a motivation or
anything along those lines it's really
great to see a lot of familiar faces
your question is I want to learn more on
how to behave during a tech internship
and how I can ask technical questions
well and not annoy engineers I apologize
a bit of a cough today that's a really
good question because the line between
being excited and being too much is a
fine line to walk and so when you're in
your tech internship the key thing that
you want to be thinking about is am I
doing this and trying to just get as
much out of everyone around me as I can
am i waste am i taking their time or am
i giving back and hey it's the holiday
season so let's think about how we can
give back to people I would say a
typical rule of thumb is you know
depending on your relationship with the
people that you're trying to connect
with and talk with you know a couple of
times a month to check in is probably
the maximum that you'll want to do
unless you're you know in that sort of
friendship zone or mentor-mentee zone if
you're reaching out to different
strangers there's a there's probably a
level at which it might be a bit too
much so just think about it from your
perspective if you if you were doing
your job and someone are reaching out to
you of
course you want to help right because we
are for sipper we all like to
reciprocate I always get that word wrong
and so when someone reaches out and they
ask for help you're gonna really want to
help them and you're gonna you know do
your best to give them a little bit of a
push
give them information make an
introduction all those different things
but at a certain point that person who
you're trying to help needs to take what
you've given them and go do something
with it on their own and so I think it's
really good to think about it from that
perspective because then you'll say
alright I've given this person a little
bit of help let's see if they come back
in a month and have done the things that
I've asked them to do or or advise them
to do so a good example of this is let's
say I have a mentor through the American
Marketing Association or something like
that and I go to them and I say you know
I'm really interested in building my
social media presence over the next year
what would be some recommendations that
you have that guy or gal would say I
really think that LinkedIn is a great
place for content right now go create
content on LinkedIn and I think that'll
really boost your presence over the next
year now if the next time I go talk to
them I say hey thanks for last week's
advice now I want to know about should I
create a website or not that person
before they start advising you on the
next piece of information that you're
looking to gather they're gonna want to
know did you do the last thing I told
you to do right so instead of going in
with a totally unrelated different
question you can say hey thank you start
with a thank you say I really appreciate
the advice that you gave me last week in
response to you telling me to do more on
LinkedIn I have posted three or four
different things here has been the
response on those things it's been
really helpful it's actually connected
me with some new people I just want to
say thank you so much for that great
advice I was also wondering if you think
a website would be a good thing to pair
with this other advice that you gave me
now they can give you a little bit more
advice they feel good because they've
seen results from what they've told from
the advice that they've shared and now
you've got a good
report knowing the thing that happens a
lot when we're networking and when we're
doing all these different things is that
we get advice from people and then we
never do anything with it and then we go
back to them and they go why do I keep
giving you advice but you never do
anything with it so you want to make
sure you're doing something with the
advice and then there's nothing there's
no better feeling in the world then
hearing that you gave someone advice
they did it and then they got a positive
response so giving them that gift of hey
what you told me worked is such a
valuable thing and so when we're
thinking about how to provide value to
people I mean just validating the fact
that their advice was helpful and that
you did it and that it worked that's so
big because now they can go into their
holiday season thinking wow last year I
really helped some people I can't wait
to do that more in 2019 so I hope that
addresses some of your questions of how
to behave you want to be pairing the
advice that you asked for with action
and results and a lot of gratitude as I
guess how I would best sum that up how
do I mention a nonworking period say six
years in such a way that the focus is on
now because tomorrow is uncertain this
is from Rick I would love Rick if you
would share in the chat here exactly
what the six year break was for was it
and what you maybe were doing or focused
on during that six year period because I
think that's going to inform this answer
quite a bit
tomorrow is uncertain I think that
sentence there tomorrow is uncertain
while true because none of us are you
know fortune tellers I think that the
thing to keep in mind about tomorrow
being uncertain is that you still have a
lot of ownership and control over what
you do today in order to inform tomorrow
and so if you're trying to talk about a
nonworking period you want to reference
you know during this period here's what
was happening
here was the transition back into trying
to get into tech or whatever it is
you're trying to accomplish and what I'm
working on today is building this
skillset maybe a certain language or
something along those lines in order to
help companies create amazing user
experiences that engage and retain their
current customers all right because now
you're not just framing it in Who am I
what do I do and and why does you know
why am I even here you're framing it in
why should they care about who you are
and what you do if what you do is create
amazing user experiences that engage and
retain current customers me as a
business owner or as a manager or
whomever I might be I go that's on my
list for this year I need to engage and
retain more customers how do you do that
and then you say well I use these
frameworks and I do X Y & Z all right
now we're in a conversation about how
you can help me solve problems and we're
not worried about the past six years
we're worried about today in the future
so I hope that that gives you some
context there if you want to share a
little bit more maybe we can get into
the nitty-gritty but I'm gonna move on
to some more questions here just to make
sure we can get through as much as
possible on the call today all right
c'mon how can I get my first freelancing
project this is a great question and
there's about a million different ways
to do it
the first and probably easiest way to
start freelancing is to put your profile
up on a number of those freelancing
websites trying to remember what they're
called off the top of my head I'm kind
of blanking on it
I think freelance comm is actually one
of them gosh there's one that's right on
the tip of my tongue if anyone knows the
names of these sites please put them in
the chat because I'm clearly getting a
little bit of a brain fart right now but
yeah there's a whole lot of different
websites out there that like Fiverr even
is a website where you can go and get
some short like project experience it
might not pay as much as some other
sites but it's a really good sort of
footing in the door another thing you
can do is reach out
volunteer organizations and
non-for-profits typically they don't
have a lot of money but they do need a
lot of help and so you can say well
because I believe in your mission and
because you know you seem like a great
organization I'd be happy to help you
know work on a project for you it'll
build my portfolio which is great it'll
help you you know solve whatever need
you might have in your in your nonprofit
right now and then you know it's just
good value both ways other things beyond
that networking with small business
owners and trying to see if asking them
questions like this like take them out
to coffee and say I'm really curious
about your business and curious what
you're trying to accomplish in 2019 and
then when you're chatting with them you
say what are you most excited about what
are you struggling with what do you wish
what projects do you wish you could
accomplish in the next year then maybe
you don't feel like you're the budget
for or the bandwidth for and then they
might throw a few ideas out and if
you're able to help with any of those
ideas you can say you know I'd be happy
to do you know depending on where you're
at I'd be happy to either you know
intern sort of and do this for free just
kind of show you my skill set you could
say you know I I can do this project for
a fairly little price if that's
something that's on your list to check
off this here or you can you know
depending on how experienced you are
negotiate your first your first client
now this is very tough if it's all new
to you it's you gotta learn a little bit
of sales skill set but it's it's
definitely play those three places
online where they're sending people to
you nonprofits where you can just you
know offer to volunteer and then small
businesses who you can really jump in
and help because they typically don't
have the bandwidth at the end of the day
to do it on their own
all right which hard programming or soft
skills could make a difference in a job
application process where a Bachelor is
missing this is Rick thank you for
another question it's hard for me to
answer the programming one since I don't
know your
programming background but typically the
way you figure out what programming
skills you need to include in your
resume and LinkedIn and other sites go
and download or not download go and
search maybe five or six job postings at
companies that you really like for job
titles that you really wish you had so
we try and make it all the same job
title so if it's like entry-level
program or whatever it might be
one thing I've done in the past which is
sort of a hit or miss but give it a shot
and see how it looks
copy and paste all the text in that in
that posting and put it into a word
cloud and see what words are used the
most in that in that in that posting and
you might do this for five or six jobs
and see a common thread going through
them all so they all want Python or they
all want C++ something like that once
you notice that all the job listings of
the job that you want have the same
skills listed in them then you make sure
that if you have those skills they are
front and center on your resume and on
your LinkedIn profile so in your
LinkedIn profile you might want to put
them in your summary and down in the
skills section at the bottom that way
the SEO crawlers when they go through
your site see all those skills you might
also see on those job postings that
there are call-outs for soft skills that
you need to include as well so again put
them in there
but soft skills are a little bit more
show than tell so if you say I'm a great
communicator or I'm a good writer it's
better to go write a bunch of articles
and publish them on LinkedIn than it is
to just say you're good at writing in
your resume so if you're really good at
communicating maybe do some videos or do
a podcast something along those lines
soft skills again are much better to
show than to tell you know even the
smallest version of that if you say
you're a good communicator go try and
get coffee with people and
actually communicate by showing those
skills are definitely the best way to go
and I would say even the hard skills as
well but you want them on your profiles
but also are you keeping your github as
up-to-date as possible is it very very
green or is it pretty much white with a
couple speckles you know definitely keep
that in mind all right
tips for applying to jobs located in a
different state who this is a tough one
Xavier okay so I can tell you how I did
it and then I can sort of speculate
about a few other things and maybe we
can brainstorm in the comments section
of how to best do this for you so when I
was applying for jobs I knew I was gonna
be moving to Austin Texas but I also
knew I wanted to work remote and what I
put on my resume
I believe was location flexible I did
that because I knew I was I was actually
at the time exploring a number of
different locations but when I was just
applying generally and I didn't know
where I wanted to be going
I wrote location flexible in the top
right corner that way they knew that I
was open to different locations and you
know if they were in New York let's say
it wouldn't be such like oh he's in
Chicago it's gonna be too big of a deal
something along those lines then when I
was applying for certain cities I put
that city in my resume as well and and I
believe I wrote something along the
lines of like Austin Texas arrival
whatever the month and date was now I
think I only did that for a couple of
the jobs that I applied to but once I
knew that I was moving and I knew I was
going to be there soon that's when I
started being very specific about the
fact that I was gonna move to Austin and
what I was trying to accomplish with
that is that I was trying to take away
the worry in their mind of having to pay
for me to relocate now that might have
still come up in the negotiations but
one of
things that I think a lot of us get a
little bit like anxiety about is if I
say that I don't live in the city are
they gonna think oh it's too much of a
hassle I don't want to talk to this
person so putting something like
location flexible or actually adding the
location that you're moving to I think
is helpful to a degree it gets a little
tricky because then they can google you
and see that you don't live in Austin or
something like that but for me I was
just very clear that it said like moving
to Austin in whatever date and then when
I was talking to people I was just very
clear that I'm always open to relocation
and I'm open to and once we got down to
negotiations being like you know is this
covered is it not you know I'm still
interested either way just being very
clear about those things yeah so I hope
that that helps a little bit and then
probably the best thing that I did when
I was think about this and I heard this
from another coach that I was chatting
with I said they recommended there that
if you knew you 100% knew that you were
gonna be moving to a place to go book a
trip spend a week in that location and
in that week try and go to as many
events and meet as many people as
possible so I actually did that I flew
to Austin for a week I everyone that I
emailed before I flew out there I said
you know I went into the LinkedIn people
search I have filtered it by location
and by job and I just said I think I
emailed maybe like 50 to 70 people
because I knew I'd only get a small
percentage of people who could meet in
that window and I said I'm gonna be here
from this state to this date I'd love to
get to buy you coffee and learn a little
bit about your work are you free and
then some people met up with me at
events some people got coffee some
people you know had different things
that they had going on that they invited
me to and I ended up just being a really
great like deadlines and instigator for
people to want to get together and and
meet and then I'd say all right I'm
heading back home I'm gonna follow up
with you I'm really excited to learn
more and see if we can continue the
conversation if there's an opportunity
to work together so I think those are
some of the different
different ways that you can build that
sort of network and and showcase that
you're looking to make a move all right
Elaine a Elaine I'm not 100% sure how to
pronounce your name so I apologize but
how should I incorporate my Udacity
projects into my resume and my job
search a great question there is a
section on LinkedIn called projects and
you can just add them in there and I
would also put the same thing on I your
resume you can do it in two ways one
have a separate section of like here's
all the projects if you're working on
projects outside of Udacity 2 you can
list them all or you can underneath your
education where you have Udacity you
also list out your projects so this is a
great question I think it really depends
on the format of your resume the amount
of detail you want to add around your
projects sorry my allergies going crazy
and so definitely put it in either the
project section the education section I
guess you'd acity wouldn't go under your
experience you don't want to necessarily
put it under there but if you want to
make your project part of your
experience and just say like maybe your
most recent job is freelance and then
you just list all the projects and one
of them is Udacity project I think that
might be ok too
gets a little bit gray there but I think
that there's a lot of different ways to
do it look up try and find some people's
profiles on LinkedIn who have their
resume listed in their profile search
the people search by the job title you
want and just kind of flip through a
dozen or so profiles until you find
someone who has a resume posted and see
how they did it that's also a good way
to do some sort of like stealthy
research to find out how other people
are doing and I think when we're
thinking about promoting ourselves which
is really what a resume is it's good to
see how other people are promote
themselves as well so might be another
helpful thing to do all right Maxim you
recommend resources for meeting new
like-minded people like how you
mentioned meetup.com I'm new in the US
and I don't know anyone awesome this is
I'm so happy this is on your mind really
like it's it's exciting when people are
trying to figure this out because
there's a lot of different ways to go
about it so you've already heard me
mention meetup.com I think it's a
wonderful site
I think there's Meena comm Eventbrite
there's online forums I know a lot of
people that get a lot of great
information from reddit I don't know how
much reddit leads to in-person
interactions but it might be a place to
check out there's a lot of LinkedIn
groups and professional organizations
that you could join as well one of the
biggest ways that I built my network in
the past was by joining a marketing
organization the American Marketing
Association and I you know worked with
them for a number of years got onto the
board for a little bit and helped run a
lot of events which kind of put my name
out there but also brought people into
my network while also promoting their
brand and promoting their network and so
there's I would say start with Meetup
also join the number of professional
organizations attend different events
buys like schools and companies so you
can take a look at the events page it
the events pages on a number of like
alumni associations hmm I'm starting to
question that one as I say it out loud
because you're not from here so maybe
you don't have an Alumni Association but
that was another thing that I did was
really tap into my alumni network if you
went to a school that has a chapter here
or if you want to start a chapter here
maybe you can find that there's a dozen
people in the city that you leave live
in who have art either from the same
country that you're from or the same
school you went to something like that
you can kind of develop these tiny
little things and then see if you can
a little some projects with people like
collaborate on something I think there's
a lot of there's a lot of opportunity to
work on things together and do
collaborative coding or
just sort of connect over projects I
actually shared something on my LinkedIn
today you might wanna go check it out it
was a video someone made about
networking for introverts and it had a
couple of really great tips in it about
why collaborating with people is so much
better than you know going to a night of
drinks or a happy hour or something like
that because when you're building
something together that's where you
that's where you create the best bonds
so I hope that kind of touches on a few
of the things you're looking for but I
think meetup.com professional
organizations if you just start with
those two you're gonna get a lot of
great connections and then use those
people that you're meeting use that that
introduction to then say hey let's go
build something together and then you
can really deepen those connections
maybe maybe you go to a professional
organization meet another person who's
similar interest to you and then go
start a sports tech meetup and now you
and them are going to rapidly expand
your network and I'll also say when you
go to a meet-up
your goal should be to have at least 1 2
3 ok conversations but just know that
meetups are a pretty tough place to
build a great rapport there's so much
noise and there's so much going on and
most of us are introverted so what you
want what you want to do is really just
like get a conversation started you know
hey how are you what do you do all that
good stuff and then say it was really
interesting chatting with you would you
be open to grabbing coffee at some point
exchanging information and grabbing
coffee and continuing this conversation
in a less noisy environment and a lot of
people are open to that so it's a good
way to sort of build on the meetup that
you went to and then the best possible
thing you can do at a meet-up is figure
out who's running it and volunteer to
help them check people in set up the
rooms find venues find speakers whatever
you can do to get to know the organizers
because it's great to attend a meet-up
but it's much better to help set up or
run your
meet up those those that's where you
need the most people all right grace
what is the best way to prepare for
interviews when sometimes companies have
different required skills hmm I would
love to get a little bit more detail
here on what skill differences you're
referring to usually if you're applying
for a role that is a very specific title
the skills will be pretty much the same
between companies because they're all
sort of working with the same templates
but what you really want to do is
reverse engineer it you want to say what
skills do I have and then what jobs are
looking for those skills right and so
and another thing to keep in mind err if
you're looking at the job description
and this is a big thing to remember and
probably the number one thing I want you
to leave with in your head today
recently I posted an article on LinkedIn
and it said that you really only need
50% of the qualifications to be
considered for a role now that seems a
bit extreme and I would say probably 60
to 70 percent in order to actually get
the job but to be considered 50 percent
so you should be sending stuff out to
companies that you know maybe seem just
a little out of reach but you know be be
self-aware know where you're at with
your skill set you know going for senior
manager job if this is your first role
in the tech space probably not going to
happen but intern versus entry-level you
know there's there's some room some gray
area there but the key thing when when
companies are I want to focus on the
first part what is the best way to
prepare for an interview so I'm gonna
dig into that a little bit so that was
actually when I would we I think we just
posted today an hour ago right before
this call when you are practicing for an
interview of the typical way that we
practice is we pull up a whole bunch of
questions like 30 40 questions from one
of those websites that says here are the
top questions for an interview and then
we go down the list and try to answer
each one individually and here's how it
typically goes
a time when you had a issue or struggle
with a co-worker and then your answer is
well this one time I had an issue or
struggle with a co-worker but we worked
it out and we were able to overcome it
and it's so broad it's so broad that I
have no idea who your coworker was what
the conflict was how bad did it get
who else had to be brought in in order
to help mediate if anyone what was your
approach to trying to resolve this did
it go well the first time did it take
multiple attempts are you on good terms
now or is there still some weird tension
but you're able to work together still
like there's so much detail that people
do not give because they've never sat
down and said it out loud before so we
end up giving these very high-level
answers to questions that lead the other
person who can't read your mind who
doesn't see the picture that's playing
in your head either scratching their
head or just going like alright give me
more on that like how did that work and
then we get it kind of flustered because
you're getting asked the same question
multiple times so the best way to
prepare for an interview and I think
this address is the second part of your
question as well which is the different
skill sets you want to be able to tell a
story so you want to have three to four
stories in your back pocket at all times
and no matter what the question that
they ask you you'll probably be able to
answer that question just by telling one
of your stories from a slightly
different perspective so let's say the
perspective is or the question is sorry
my allergies are going crazy let's say
the question is tell me a time that you
struggled with a co-worker all right
well you had this project that you
worked on the project had people that
you collaborated well with people that
you struggled with it had highs that had
lows it had a point where you thought
the whole thing was gonna crash and had
a point where things were really going
well and then it resolved itself and it
all worked out in the end so that's
story whatever it might be if they say
tell me a time you've had a struggle
with a co-worker you could say well this
one time we were building we realize
that there is a problem that needed to
be solved we saw
building a solution and then while
building a solution you know I was
interacting with Dan and Dan and I just
had very different approaches to solving
this problem and then you finished
telling the story with that little bit
of a me and Dan had a conflict but we
still got to the end then they can say
it was a time that you had a great
experience working with a co-worker and
you can say you know that same project
we were working on while I was having
the struggle with Dan you know me and
Karen we're actually like you know we
got this like I know that this part is
getting a little shaky but we got this
other piece down and we would meet on a
regular basis and we would work on it
and we would do a really good job we get
to the end and then kind of now now
they're seeing that you understand that
there's a lot of nuance and you can
actually explain how every story that
you have has multiple perspectives I and
that's why I say have like three or four
of those ready that way probably three
or four of your favorite things that
you've worked on and then you can really
answer a lot of questions and showcase
soft skills hard skills and everything
else in between just by kind of changing
your approach to how you tell each one
of those stories and the best thing
about them is if you have three or four
you can practice them over and over
again you can record yourself and hear
yourself practicing those things out
loud and then when you hear it out loud
you'll go oh I forgot to mention this
detail or I said um three hundred times
that in that story or wow I really went
off on a ramble and I never quite got
back to the story when I said at that
time so we're gonna chop that part down
and the more you practice these stories
the more fluidly they'll come out during
an interview and the better you'll be at
telling stories in general and so go
check out LinkedIn our most recent post
about storytelling and it's also on
YouTube in the Udacity career tips
playlist that should be the newest one
that's on their career tip 13 so do you
want to get a little bit more detail I
actually tell a specific story of
someone I worked with who went from high
level to highly specific
all right Alexis how do you transition
into an entirely new industry I love
this question so the first question that
I have in response to that is what
industry are you in and what industry
are you transferring in are you trying
to transfer into a lot of times when I
hear this question and I say what
industry do you want to be in people
just say well I don't want to be in this
industry
and it's funny because it's this idea of
are you running away from something or
are you running towards something now at
most points in our lives
we're doing both we're running away from
something we don't like and we're
running towards something that we do but
if we're only focused on the thing that
we're running away from then when we go
and talk to someone who let's say works
in self-driving cars or I don't know
drones whatever the thing might be that
we're really interested in or that we
think we're interested in we sit down
and talk to them and they say why do you
want to work at this company why do you
want to move into this industry and we
say well this last thing I was working
on it wasn't very fun so I'm trying
something new
well that doesn't inspire them that
doesn't make them feel you know excited
about you that just makes them be like
well I'm so glad to be a stepping stone
on your way to whatever's next right and
what we want to do is we want to sit
down and say what industry am i
interested in why am i interested in it
and then how do I meet people who are
also interested in it so this is where
the idea of nerding out instead of
networking comes into play so what we
want to say is like all right so I'm
really interested in self-driving cars
why I was actually chatting with someone
recently and she said she'd never owned
a car before moving to America and then
when she moved here she was basically
the chauffeur for her family and so like
she was driving cars all the time and
now she wants to move into self-driving
cars and I'm like you've got to tell
that story during an interview like you
have to it's it's such a great motivator
because then she could say like gosh if
the car would just drive itself I could
work on X Y or Z and said
I could not worry like I can't wait for
this future where we all just press the
uber button and a self-driving car picks
us up and we don't have to drive it off
we don't have to do anything like that
future is so enticing because I'm not a
big fan of driving now that is like a
great story to know and internally and
be able to tell in an interview but then
to go deeper into your question how do
you transition into entirely new
industry you have to let the world know
what you want to do and the way that you
do that is by creating an elevator pitch
that explains sort of you know the goal
that you're trying to do for her it's AI
she's a designer so she's like I really
look forward to a world of autonomous
cars and beautiful design and I want to
be part of it I want to make the inside
these autonomous vehicles look cool I
want to be you know part of this
industry
and then a great way to sort of leverage
your personal abilities and your
personal perspective is to create
content around it so are you posting on
social media are you sharing things are
you creating things
how are you putting yourself out there
and updating your profiles to showcase
what you used to do what you are
currently working on new skills you're
building and the things that you hope to
accomplish in the future the industry
you want to be in so you want to be in
the conversation if you're not in the
conversation either in person or online
and preferably both you're gonna be
missing out and you're gonna just be
trapped in your own bed so I would say
try and get out of your head and into
the conversation
Ricardo Ricardo asks a question about
he's working as a machine learning
engineer right now and he's looking for
a role in the US but without a degree
it's been really hard to get sponsorship
should I spend my savings on a degree
from the US hmm gosh this is a really
tough one because I I've never been in
this situation so I want to just be
clear that I'm not an expert especially
when it comes to visas and and all those
different things but I think it's a at
the end of the day what you're looking
at here is an ROI question because
you're talking about your savings and
you know trying to get to the US so your
goal isn't necessarily a degree your
goal is a degree in order to get
sponsorship in order to get to the u.s.
so the first question I have is are
there any other ways to get your visa
sponsorship if there's no other way to
get that sponsorship except to get a
degree then we need to really take that
bet option seriously if and then when we
say alright we want to get a degree
there's a lot of different types of
degrees out there so you can do an
online program you can do an in-person
program Ivy League schools cost a lot of
money but some of the more like smaller
private or liberal arts schools don't
cost so much money what exactly is the
ROI on the money you're gonna spend how
much do you have in your savings how
much are you willing to lose if it
doesn't work out gosh there's just so
much in this question Ricardo I wish I
could give you a solid answer and tell
you what to do but I think you've got to
sit down and do the calculation and see
if it's worth the cost if getting to
America and getting a job here because
you already have a job as a machine
learning engineer so you clearly have
the skill set it could be a very good
option and there could be a cheap way to
do it maybe you can get a scholarship
I'm not sure so do a little bit more
research on exactly what that ROI is and
if it's a
or risk or if you're up for the
high-risk and high-reward I wouldn't say
no to it but know why you're doing it if
you're doing it because you think it'll
get you a job like a lot of people you
know it's like you have people spending
eighty thousand dollars on an art degree
boy I would I would HIGHLY question
whether or not you should go back to
school and get an art degree if you try
and be like a painter or something you
know there's a lot of nuance in this one
but I hope that helped a little bit and
now you're thinking of it from an ROI
perspective we have another one from tan
here I've been living in the u.s.
without a college degree I've completed
five nano degrees what are my chances of
getting a job without being filtered out
right away again this is a real tough
question you have five the Nano degrees
so this might be an odd thing for me to
say but I think you probably need to
stop getting more education and start
going out and building things if this is
a thing called productive
procrastination where people get more
and more and more certifications and
degrees and doing all these sort of
things but they never actually go in and
do the work that they're supposed to be
doing it's kind of postponing it through
education so going back to one of our
earlier questions here how do I start
getting freelance work can you join any
of those websites can you reach out to
any volunteer whose age you start
building your portfolio so you have a
very strong body of work when you walk
into these companies and talk to people
and then really analyze the way that
you're searching for a job is the reason
you're not getting a job because you
don't have a degree or is it because
you've only been applying to jobs
through online job sites and you haven't
been doing any networking I think a lot
of times people think that the reason
they're not getting a job is because of
X Y or Z I'm too young or I'm too old or
I don't have enough education but really
what it is that they haven't developed a
network and they don't know anyone who
could get them the job so they're stuck
behind this weird internet
where there's about 20 different layers
of barriers between you and the person
that makes a decision you've got you
your resume your cover letter
the online page be like artificial
intelligence filter the hiring or the HR
filter than the hiring manager filter
then like the higher up filter like
there's just so many people between you
and that job you've got to get around
that system and talk to a real human
being so I would say take a look at the
whole thing before you just put it all
on one because with any problem that we
have in our entire lives its
multivariable so try and control as many
variables as you can and then if you're
really not finding work I think I don't
know what the chances are but I think
that's when you gotta say well what
exactly is the thing preventing me and
maybe you have to build your own thing
uh in the short term in order to build
up enough cred enough leverage in order
to be able to say I can do this for your
company alright Mohammed I'm searching
for entry-level jobs in data science and
I found that most of that requires two
years of minimal experience to be a fit
what do I do
gosh I love this question two years of
experience for an entry-level role it's
counterintuitive right how do I get two
years of experience if I need two years
of experience it's one of those like
yeah it's a catch-22 it's it really is
one of those things where I wonder why
we do this like I wonder why people that
create these job listings have that
requirement in there for a job that is
clearly the lowest entry into their
company and what I think the reason is
and this is you know a bit speculative
on my part but what I think the reason
is is that if you're told by your
manager to put together a job
description and hire someone new and you
go up to them you say here's the job
description can you approve
for I posted online and they read
through it and it says we are looking
for someone with zero years of
experience they're gonna go by zero like
why not say too and see if we can catch
someone who's higher level right like
why not you they might very well find
someone who has three years of
experience who's totally willing to do
that job so they say you know minimum
two years of experience why not
because there's a lot of people out
there looking for jobs however we I
think what we need to do with this
question is expand what are our internal
idea of experience is what does
experience mean what we think it means
is two years of experience doing this
exact role or working with this exact
technology which most technologies
aren't even two years old so how the
heck like social media managers with two
years experience maybe now you can find
that but they were saying that when
having someone running your Twitter is
was like a customer service job like
this is a totally different world that
we live in so what I think you need to
start thinking about is what do I
consider experience is it my previous
work experience is it my education is it
my projects is it something that's hyper
specific to this role what does
experience mean to me and then if you
have a good confidence around it and
story to tell and you can really
communicate not only what your past
experiences but your current learnings
and your future work all kind of mesh
together to come then you can blow past
that question pretty easily and I like I
said earlier you really only need fifty
to seventy percent of the qualifications
to apply so I would say give it a shot
you know if it says two years experience
maybe they get somewhat two years
experience maybe they don't a lot of
times companies put their ideal
candidate on that listing but they know
they're only gonna get someone who has a
handful of those things and they're okay
with that and so I would say apply and
then reach out to people at the company
who are in that job and figure out what
their experience is so easiest way to do
that go on LinkedIn look up the come
I look up their employees filter by the
job title and then look at their
background and experience if they have
experience that is pretty similar to
yours you should be able to get into
that role and then reach out to that
person and ask them are all the things
on this listing what really matter or is
this kind of like a longshot like
they're just hoping to get the best
possible person and you might find that
as you're talking to these people like
you know it says Python on there but we
never use it like we're in a totally
different programming language I don't
know how it will play out but I wouldn't
never be the person that says no you
want them to say no you are yes until
they say no I think it's the best way I
can put it all right we're getting to
last 10 minutes and getting a little
hoarse but we're gonna try and get in as
many questions as we can I do you have
any more um please put them in the chat
and we'll save them for the next one or
for any other videos that we make well
should i bin' how should I apply for
engineering jobs in the US when I live
in Germany what do they look at first
degree skills job experience I would say
they probably look at your job
experience first they filter by skills
especially with online programs degree
is is comes after all of that that's a
quick answer to your question the longer
answer to your question is make inroads
with the companies because the best
possible thing that could happen with
your application your resume or
something like that is if you apply for
a job but you've already talked with
people
excuse me you've already talked with
people who work at the company
so you apply for the job then they pass
your resume along internally and you get
an internal referral and then that
person who interviews you goes oh cool
tell me about yourself
like you want them to spend that much
time looking your credentials because
you've already done the work ahead of
time in order to build strong
relationships within the company and so
it
gonna be tough from Germany and you're
gonna have to figure out how to network
via Skype and you're gonna have to
figure out how to connect with people
via email but it's not impossible
so I would highly recommend you know
taking a look at some of the videos that
we posted so far but also just giving it
a shot like worst case scenario people
ignore you say not right now or you
maybe fumble and then you just move on
to one of the other 10,000 people that
you could potentially reach out to all
right I believe your name is Myron but
I'm so sorry I'm terrible at pronouncing
names if you can correct me in the
comments I would very much appreciate
that I'm learning I'm learning how to
pronounce names startups vs. big
companies as a fresh graduate what's
your take and how can I improve my
career search and motivation in general
I think we'll end on these two questions
all right so startups versus big
companies there are three things that I
typically see people worrying about when
trying to decide what job they want to
take the first one is money the second
one is skillset and the third one is
people or culture so when you're looking
at your job search my question to you is
what is the most important thing for you
right now now this might change
throughout your life but are you most in
need of money and financial security are
you most in need to build a skill set or
you most in need to be around people
that are energizing so let's say you're
in your early 20s
you're still exploring your main goal is
to surround yourself a really curious
startup minded people who are like
constantly building and asking questions
and doing cool things maybe you take
less money and you'll work any job in
that company like early Facebook or
something you know people are just doing
whatever needs to be done
in order to have that experience of
working with a bunch of like you know if
it's a team of three people and you join
it as the fourth person you're gonna be
wearing a lot of hats so you won't worry
about your skill set and you probably
won't get paid much because they don't
have much coming in but let's switch it
around a bit let's say culture is what's
most important to you and the NB am i
mixing this up as i say it let me think
money skill set and people so we are
touched on culture so that would be the
you're putting the skill to the side and
you're putting the money to the side to
be a surrounded by good people number
two you want to build a specific skill
set you really want to learn how to how
to code a certain language or you want
to learn how to write or you want to
learn how to do video or whatever the
thing is that you want to learn you
could actually you care less about the
culture and the people and you care less
about the money as long as you're
building this skill sex you know they'll
pay dividends in the future so you take
the skill set over the other two things
and again you can prioritize these in
order of what you think is most and
least important to you right now they're
all going to be important by the way
it's not like any of them are off the
table you don't want to go to a company
with terrible people in it just cuz it
has a skill set and then finally if
you're in a place where financials are
the most important thing maybe you put
skill set number two and people number
three and you go work in a in a little
bit more of a stiff environment or
something like that because that's what
you need right now so I would say you
really need to figure out what your
priority is in those three areas and
then you can sort of find the right
company based off of that breakdown and
then how can I improve my career search
and motivation in general the best way
you can do this is to figure out how to
be held accountable for your job search
now sometimes that's getting a coach but
I can get pricey sometimes it's finding
other people who are searching for a job
right now and just like having a weekly
check-in with them either on the phone
email or even in person over coffee when
I was working at a start-up a while back
I was a career
and did open to other stuff for them but
one of the things I did was I did
coaching for their graduates and when I
tried to do for everyone was have a
phone call every morning at 7 a.m.
because I noticed that the main thing
that people were struggling with was
just getting out of bed when they didn't
have a structure to their day so people
waking up at noon they weren't starting
their job search until 1:00 p.m. there's
a big mess so I said everyone get on
skype by 7:00 in the morning and then
whatever you do after that because now
you're awakened out of bed you know it's
better than just missing the whole day
so that was something that I did for
those folks but I think if you can build
this in your own way to go to a few
events meet some other job seekers and
say every Wednesday we're gonna get
coffee and check in on progress because
that's I think the hardest thing for the
job search is just being held
accountable and if you're all holding
each other accountable and you're
helping each other out maybe you can't
get each other a job but you can get
each other motivated and I think that
that's why the best way to go about it
all right is I lose my voice toward the
end of this call we are hitting the 3
o'clock the end of the hour I 3 o'clock
my time I know everyone's into different
time zone but thank you so much for
joining the call today gosh is just so
fun to like get these questions and just
see how deep we could get in the time
that we have we do these calls every
single week so please sign up for the
next second session which is on the 3rd
of January coming up invite other people
share with other job seekers you know
maybe this is your accountability call
every week to get a good kick in the
butt motivation hey I'd be happy to be
that person that pushes you a little bit
fill out the type form that Karen is
gonna be sharing with you all as well
and if you have any questions between
now and next week feel free to share it
in slack in in the YouTube or LinkedIn
comments on the career tip videos I'll
be seeing all those as they come through
as well and and or just reach out to us
directly and if you're here and you want
to connect with other job seekers like I
said to keep each other
motivated put your LinkedIn's in the
chat or wherever you want to share them
so that you can all connect with each
other and maybe create a big old group
where you're all you know keeping each
other motivated you know I have a couple
more minutes here so I'm just gonna
answer this last question once or touch
on to see if I I have it ready yet when
switching a job to a new field does the
recruiter or hiring manager consider any
existing experience as an asset or
liability Prashant maybe we'll hold this
one for the next the next call but
existing experience I in my opinion I'm
not quite sure I understand your
question but I think any existing
experience is good experience as long as
you talk about it the right way so we
can come back and go into more detail
next week but thank you all so much for
joining this has been a blast and I look
forward to to chatting again next week
and hearing more of your questions
things coming up